THE WATER LOUIS GIULIANI HE WILL
NOT TESTIFY UNTIL THERE HAS BEEN
A FORMAL IMPEACHMENT VOTE AND
ITS CHAIRMAN ADAM SCHIFF IS
REMOVED.
END OF THE BOYD SWOOPED
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM, HE HAS
INVITED GIULIANI TO TESTIFY
ABOUT POSSIBLE CORRUPTION IN
UKRAINE.
WILL HE ACCEPT THIS OFFER?
RUDY GIULIANI,
JOSEPH DiGENOVA, ARE YOU GOING
TO TESTIFY WITH THE SENATE?
AT >> I HAVE TO WEIGH THAT WITH
MY CLIENT, IT'S NOT A UNITARY
DECISION BUT IT MAY AFFECT THE
OTHER DECISIONS.
I WOULD LOVE TO TESTIFY AND GIVE
ME A HALF-HOUR TO POINT OUT
BIDEN INC., FOUR DECADES OF
CRIME.
IT WILL BE EASIER THAN POINTING
OUT SIX DECADES OF MAFIA CRIME.
>> Laura: WHAT WAS GOING ON
WITH PERRY?
>> HE'S DONE NOTHING WRONG.
>> Laura: HE WAS AT THE
INAUGURATION OF ZELENSKY.
>> SENATOR CHRIS MURPHY TOLD
ZELENSKY HE BETTER NOT COOPERATE
WITH ME AND OTHER SENATORS TOLD
HIM NOT TO COOPERATE WITH
WILLIAM BARR.
>> Laura: DID YOU DEBRIEF HIM?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO TELL YOU MY
INTERNAL CONVERSATIONS, I TALKED
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Laura: CORY BOOKER IS
SOMEONE WHO IS CHOMPING AT THE
BIT TO QUESTION YOU.
>> I WOULD SAVOR THE OPPORTUNIT
OPPORTUNITY, ESPECIALLY IF IT'S
DONE PUBLICLY.
I KNOW RUDY GIULIANI IS FROM
NEW YORK, VERY CLOSE TO
BROADWAY, HE LOVES THE
THEATRICS, HIS BEHAVIOR HAS BEEN
DESPICABLE AND THE LIES AND
HALF-TRUTHS AND THE DECEPTION
THAT HE HAS BEEN DOING AT THE
DIRECTION OF THIS PRESIDENT AND
BEYOND IS UNBECOMING.
>> Laura: UNBECOMING,
DESPICABLE, GARDEN-VARIETY
INSULTS.
>> I HAVE TO GO INTO THE ARENA
WITH SPARTACUS?
I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD HANDLE
IT, HE'S A TOUGH GUY.
I DON'T KNOW.
HE SCARES ME.
HE WAS A TERRIBLE MAYOR, WHEN I
WAS A MAYOR OF THE CITY I TURNED
IT AROUND, WHEN HE WAS MAYOR
THEY HAD MORE CRIME.
NEWARK IS DOING FABULOUS.
>> Laura: EVERYONE'S A TOUGH
GUY.
BIDEN HAS BEEN OFF THE TRAIL
SINCE FRIDAY, YOU NEVER SEE
BIDEN.
>> DID YOU SEE BIDEN TODAY, HE
LOST IT TODAY.
HE STARTED YELLING AT A
REPORTER, FIRST IT LOOKED LIKE
HE WAS SLEEPING.
I THINK IN LAS VEGAS.
>> Laura: HERE'S WHAT SOURCES
TOLD THE WASHINGTON EXAMINER'S
BYRON YORK -- THE IG SAID THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER HAD A
PROFESSIONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH
ONE OF THE 2020 CANDIDATES.
IF THIS TURNS OUT TO BE TRUE, AS
IN THE DEMOCRATS KEEPING HIS OR
HER IDENTITY A SECRET A TOTAL
JOKE?
>> THIS IS WHY THE NOTION THAT
YOU ARE GOING TO KEEP THESE
WITNESSES SECRET, WHY YOU ARE
TRYING TO NULLIFY AN ELECTION,
COMMIT REGICIDE AND REMOVE A
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS LUDICROUS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD, FUSION GPS WAS
INVOLVED WITH THIS PERSON, THIS
ANONYMOUS INFORMANT, I REFUSE TO
CALL HIM A WHISTLE-BLOWER
BECAUSE HE IS NOT A
WHISTLE-BLOWER UNDER THE LAW.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT THERE IS A
FORMER FBI AGENT WHO WORKED WITH
THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER AS HE IS NOW
CALLED.
WE ARE GOING TO LEARN AN AWFUL
LOT ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS
PERSON NEVER WROTE THIS
DOCUMENT, HE WAS DRAFTED BY A
COMMITTEE OF POLITICAL
CONSULTANTS AND RESEARCHERS AND
PEOPLE AFFILIATED WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE.
>> Laura: ADAM SCHIFF SHOULD
NOT BE RUNNING THIS.
HE LIED ABOUT CONTACT WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION, HE JUST LIED.
>> ADAM SCHIFF IS A WITNESS, YOU
CAN PRESIDE OVER A HEARING WHERE
YOU ARE A WITNESS.
HOW COULD IT BE POSSIBLE IF WE
CAN'T TEST THE CREDIBILITY OF
THESE WITNESSES?
YOU CAN'T COME TO A CONCLUSION
UNLESS YOU GET A CHANCE TO TEST
CREDIBILITY.
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS LAW FIRM WAS
OFFERING MONEY, THEY WERE
OFFERING HELP WITH YOUR
MORTGAGE, EXPENSES, THEY WERE
PRODDING WITNESSES TO COME
FORWARD.
YOU DON'T THINK I WOULD WANT TO
CROSS-EXAMINE THE WITNESS?
DID YOU READ IT?
DID THEY OFFER YOU ANY MONEY,
DID YOU SEE SCHIFF?
>> Laura: THIS CAN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN.
>> HERE IS THE DEAL.
THIS INSPECTOR GENERAL IS A.
WHEN HE WROTE THAT ANALYSIS, HE
WAS WRONG ABOUT THE LAW.
THIS IS NOT A MATTER OF GREAT
CONCERN, URGENT CONCERN, HE GOT
SLAPPED DOWN WHEN THEY ANALYZED
THE FACT THIS GUY MICHAEL
ATKINSON IS A.
THERE'S NO WAY AROUND HOW BAD A
JOB HE DID.
HE IS AN EMBARRASSMENT TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
>> Laura: NOW WE KNOW THERE IS
A 2020 CONNECTION, 2020 DEMOCRAT
CONNECTION TO THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND SOMEONE TRIED
TO CRITICIZE HER QUESTION BYRON
YORK'S REPORTING TONIGHT, WAS IT
AXIOS?
IT WAS JUST FINE, HE'S RIGHT ON,
BYRON YORK IS SPOT ON IN HIS
REPORTING ABOUT THIS.
>> Laura: IT'S GOING TO GET
WORSE.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT ORDERED
GORDON SOMNOLENT NOT TO APPEAR
FOR HIS DEPOSITION WITH HOUSE
INVESTIGATORS, IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE WHICH OF COURSE IS DRAWING
THE IRE OF SCHIFF, WATCH.
>> THE FAILURE TO PRODUCE THIS
WITNESS, THE FAILURE TO PRODUCE
THE DOCUMENTS, WE CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL STRONG EVIDENCE OF
CONSTRUCTION, A COEQUAL BRANCH
OF GOVERNMENT.
>> Laura: IF YOU ASSERT A
PRIVILEGE, EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE,
DELIBERATIVE PROCESS PRIVILEGE,
YOU ARE GUILTY OF OBSTRUCTION --
THERE'S NO WINNING IN THIS
SCENARIO.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO EXPLAIN TO
LITTLE SCHIFF THAT PROPOUNDING
AND PRESENTING A FALSE,
COMPLETELY FALSE NARRATIVE,
SOMEONE'S GUILT IS CALLED
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE.
HE DID IT, HE DID IT RIGHT IN
FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, HE
DID IT FOR ABOUT 20 MINUTES.
HE DID A TOTAL, FICTITIOUS CLAIM
AND HE DID IT AGAIN EARLIER WHEN
HE CLAIMED HE HAD EVIDENCE OF
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
SCHIFF, WHERE IS YOUR EVIDENCE?
YOU'RE A LIAR, I'M CALLING YOU
OUT AS A LAWYER, WHERE'S YOUR
EVIDENCE?
>> Laura: THEY ARE HITTING
GORDON SONDLAND BECAUSE HE WAS A
BIG DONOR FOR TRUMP.
DOES ANYONE REMEMBER WHO OBAMA'S
DONORS WERE?
THERE WAS HEADLINE AFTER
HEADLINE COMPLAINING ABOUT --
THAT'S JUST WHAT IT IS.
UNLESS YOU'RE A CAREER DIPLOMAT,
STOP GOING AFTER TRUMP BECAUSE
OBAMA --
>> JUST WATCHING THAT TAPE OF
SCHIFF, WATCHING HIM BUG EYED
PERFORMING LIKE A LOON AND
MOUTHING THESE -- IT'S JUST DUMB
AND STUPID AND UNSUPPORTABLE
LEGALLY.
THIS IS THE CHAIRMAN OF A MAJOR
COMMITTEE AND PELOSI TRYING TO
KEEP THE DENTURES AND WHILE
SHE'S TALKING TO THEM IS JUST
THERE ABIDING BY THIS, IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> IT WOULD BE FUNNY IF IT
WASN'T HORRIBLE TRASHING OF OUR
CONSTITUTION.
THAT HAS REPERCUSSIONS.
IT KEEPS OUR COUNTRY BETTER,
DIVIDED.
IF THEY THINK THINKS LIKE THEM.
>> Laura: THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIVING THEIR LIVES.
I WANT TO END WITH WHAT PAT
WROTE AT THE END OF HIS LETTER.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAS A COUNTRY
TO LEAD, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ELECTED HIM TO DO HIS JOB AND HE
REMAINS FOCUSED ON FULFILLING
HIS PROMISE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IF HE HAS IMPORTANT WORK THAT
MUST CONTINUE ON THEIR BEHALF AT
HOME AND AROUND THE WORLD.
I GET THAT PEOPLE ARE UPSET --
INFRASTRUCTURE, ALL THESE THINGS
ARE IMPORTANT, THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE TO KEEP DOING THE
PEOPLES BUSINESS.
>> ROOTING OUT HIGH-LEVEL
CORRUPTION IS ENORMOUS.
>> Laura: HOW CONFIDENT ARE
YOU IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS?
YOU'RE GOING TO KNOW A LOT MORE
FROM HOROWITZ, DURHAM, AND THE
REST.
YOU WILL NEVER BE AN